Today is our midterm examination. A
chance for you to question and examine
me. All right. So before we look at the
questions for the midterm examination, I
want to discuss briefly the ceasefire
between United States and Iran. So
yesterday um Donald Trump announced that
there will be a two-week pause to this
war and that the United States in Iran
will meet in Pakistan to negotiate a
possible long-term ceasefire. And what
he said that's very important is that he
will use the 10point Iranian plan as a
framework
to discuss a peace treaty. And as you
can see from the 10point plan, in fact
um this is almost a complete US
surrender to
Iran. The first point is that the United
States will guarantee never to attack
Iran again.
Um Iran will have complete control over
the shumus.
Iran can choose to enrich uranium for
its nuclear program.
All sanctions on Iran will be removed.
This is a very big deal.
um removal of all secondary sanctions
against foreign entities that do
business with Iran
and of and of all United Nations
Security Council resolutions against
Iran
and of all international Atomic Energy
Agency resolutions.
Compensation reparations for all the
damage that United States and Israel did
to Iran.
withdrawal of US combat forces from the
Middle East, giving Iran control over
the Middle East. Now, last and the most
important is that United States will
also agree to end hostilities
against all of um Iran's proxies
including Hezbollah and the Houthies in
Yemen. So, as you can see, this is
basically a complete US surrender to
Iran, which tells us right right away
that Donald Trump is not serious.
If you go into a shop and you negotiate
with a with a shop owner and you want to
sell maybe a book to the guy and you're
hoping for $100, but because it's
bargaining, you think, "Oh, um, maybe I
should start high." So, you say $1,000.
If you say $1,000 and the shop owner
says, "Yeah, go. Yeah, I'll take that
deal."
There's something wrong here. Okay. All
right. So, there's something very wrong.
And there's very little chance that the
ceasefire will hold. And in fact, we're
already seeing news that this ceasefire
is being broken. Okay. So, there are
three uh individuals on Twitter who've
made some very interesting points. All
right. So in this tweet
uh Mr. Bojac said that listen um if this
is really a ceasefire why is United
States continue to send aircraft
carriers the USS George Bush to the
Middle East? What they're really trying
to do is buy time in order for the
ground troops to get ready to attack and
seize the strait. Okay. So once
everything is in position then probably
what will happen is that Israel will
launch a false flag against the
Americans which will justify an American
attack against Iran. Right? So that's a
possible scenario. But again the
question is if this is really a
ceasefire, if Donald Trump is really
intent on peace, why does he continue to
send US forces to the Middle East?
That's question number one. Question
number two is the problem is how the how
Iran is defending itself. It's using
something called the Mosiac defense
which is say that there's 31 provinces
and these are 31 cells or units that are
all responsible for their own strategy
and attack and defense. Meaning that
there's no longer a centralized command.
So it doesn't matter if you negotiate
with the leadership of Iran because the
IRGC,
the people who are fighting will not
agree to a ceasefire because they do not
trust the Americans or the Israelis.
So whatever happens in Pakistan will not
affect the outcome of the battlefield.
That's a problem with the Mosak defense.
Think of the Mosak defense as almost a
dead man switch where if you kill the
Ayatollah, the Ayatollah will tell his
people to fight to the end. So the most
defense will only come to an end if
either Iran is defeated or the Americans
are defeated. This thing collapses if
there's in between a ceasefire because
in order for the Iranians to implement a
ceasefire, they themselves will have to
go and control these Mosak units in the
provinces, which basically means a civil
war. Okay? So it's almost impossible
even if Iran were to negotiate a
favorable peace deal for Iran to
actually implement this peace deal
within its military. Okay, that's
problem number two. Problem number three
is [snorts] the United States continues
to have an airbridge to the Middle East.
So even though there's a ceasefire, you
have these massive movement of US ground
troops, of US planes, of US artillery
and tanks to the Middle East.
So if there's really a peace, why is
this happening? And another way of
saying this is that the political
systems of both United States and Iran
have lost control over the war. Once
these militaries start fighting, they
are determined to fight to the bitter
end. Okay. But unfortunately,
um,
what this tells me, the fact that Iran
is willing to negotiate a peace treaty
probably means that there's a schism or
divide between the political leadership
in Iran and the military leadership in
Iran. And this is going to cause a lot
of problems in the future. So maybe
before this past month, it seemed as
though that Iran had control over the
battlefield and Iran was winning winning
it. But I think over time,
what's going to happen is that fissures
will arise in Iran and Iran will start
losing the battle more and more as the
United States and Israel develop a much
more coherent strategy against Iran.
Another major issue is that as this war
drags on, the world economy is going to
suffer, which means that people can no
longer drive their cars and which means
maybe a lot of people will also starve.
And this means that ultimately public or
global opinion will slowly turn against
Iran.
Okay? and even Iran's closest allies,
Russia and China will feel the strain of
this war and maybe even pressure Iran to
end this war. But again, as we discussed
previously, [snorts]
because of the way that Iran has
structured its military defense, it is
impossible for Iran to end this war
unless it's either destroyed or it's
destroyed the Americans. Okay. So, this
war um this ceasefire, it's only a PR
stunt. It will actually lead to nothing.
All right.
The major um point, okay, of contention
is whether or not Lebanon
is part of the peace treaty. So [snorts]
the the Iranians believe that this peace
treaty also includes its proxies
specifically
in Lebanon and the Houthies in in Yemen.
But after this peace treaty was
announced, Israel launched more than 100
strikes in 10 minutes across Lebanon
killing 250 people at least 250 people.
Okay. So
Iran is obligated to defend Hezbollah
morally. Um and Israel understands that
if Iran breaks the peace treaty and
defense has uh then it is Iran's fault.
Okay. And the Americans have come out
and said that well you know we agreed
that Lebanon was not part of the deal.
Um
and uh JD Vance the
um vice president said oh it's a
legitimate misunderstanding.
[gasps]
We thought that Hezbollah wasn't part of
this deal, but the Iranians thought it
was. Okay, so this is misunderstanding.
Okay, but this tells you that uh the
Americans and Israel release are not
serious about maintaining the ceasefire.
Okay, they've already found a loophole.
All right. Okay. So, let's now go on to
the midterm examination.
And um as I said um YouTube can ask me
questions and I will try my best to
answer them. So uh this uh Twitter
account RS app did a very nice thing and
basically analyze all 8,000 plus
questions and broke it down into some
major categories. All right. So what
what I'm going to do first is I will
look at these questions and then answer
them. All right. and and then we'll look
at some other questions. All right. So
the first question is all right I said
that the empire is declining but at the
same time the US could benefit from this
war. How do I reconcile the
contradiction? And the answer is um is
that really a contradiction? United
States is extremely powerful. It's
really a question of who benefits from
these changes. So even though the US
empire will lose control over the Middle
East, the the America American uh nation
can still exert control over Mexico and
Canada. Okay, this something I will
discuss later on. That's number one.
What's the role of esquetology
um in shipping global events? How do you
account for the influence of six
societies? All right, so these are the
same question and I I'll answer it right
now. All right, so let's examine how all
this works.
>> [snorts]
>> All right. So, first thing you you need
to understand is that
history
moves
in a certain direction. Okay, it's very
complicated. It's very messy. But there
is a structure and a pattern to the
movement of history.
Okay, a structure
and a pattern. So, think of a river.
Okay, when you see a river current, you
think, I can't see anything. It's just
going to be chaos. But if you if you're
able to read the river well, you know
how the river is moving. Okay? So you
can position your canoe or k in a way
that allows you to seamlessly smoothly
cross the river. All right? So that's
the idea. Okay? But this is all very
chaotic. So what so what happens is that
there are certain individuals we can
call them occultists
who try to read the river or try to read
historical patterns in history and they
create something called in
esquetology.
Okay. So think of the stars when you try
to read the stars and try to find
meaning of stars. We call this
astrology. Right? But when you try to
read human history and you try to find a
pattern in human history, we can call
this esquetology.
And the thing about the esque
esquetology is that it's a story.
And so you want the story to work out.
So it's both a prophecy as well as a
plan.
You think it's going to happen, but you
also think that you are obligated to
make it happen as well. Okay. So the
occultists, these are religious people,
they try to turn the chaotic movement of
history into a story that comes to an
end and which you can participate in.
All right. Okay.
Then from these occultists are form
secret societies
in order to understand this esquetology
and also also to promote this
esquetology.
Now what happens is that
powerful people, okay, powerful people,
the rich and the powerful,
they join these societies. Why? Because
as a rich and powerful person, you want
to know how history moves in order to
better position yourself in order to
protect your power and your wealth.
Okay, that that's why very famous people
they often have astrologers to work for
them and that's why rich and powerful
people join secret societies because
they want access to this secrets that
tells them how to uh make better
investments and how to have more
political power. Also, secret societies
enable them to create networks in order
to maintain their power. Okay. But the
problem is that you need people to
actually move towards the ending to
propel this esquetology. And these
people we can call um agents. Okay.
Agents.
[snorts]
And these agents of course include
Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin.
Okay. And this is how the world works.
where the occultists are the ones who
imagine the world and the rich and
powerful are the ones who act out the
world in order to better themselves and
then they appoint certain agents
who are like puppets in order to move
the world in a certain direction. Okay,
so these agents are like vectors.
All right, but there's certain problems
with this system.
The first problem is that there are
different societies and they fight
amongst themselves to achieve different
esquetologies. Okay. The other problem
is that the rich and powerful will often
switch secret societies, switch
loyalties in order to maximize their
benefit. So they don't have any
loyalties.
All right. And then the last problem is
that these agents like Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin, they seem like puppets,
but they themselves believe they are
using these secretities to achieve their
own vision which is given to them by
God.
Okay. So, it's a very complicated system
and this is why
no one thinks that it's all grand
conspiracy because each person is doing
his his or her own part subconsciously
to maximize his or her benefit. Okay?
So, it's not a top- down system. It's a
much more dynamic fluid game than people
um assume. Okay? So this is a map that
helps us understand how the world works
and this is why I'm able to figure out
what's happening in the moon east
because if you're able to focus on the
story okay the story here you basically
know where people are going even though
you may not be aware of what the
different secret societies are doing and
how the different agents are thinking.
Okay. As long as you're able to figure
out their cultist, how they're thinking,
you figure you're able to figure out the
story that they want to tell the world,
you can basically figure out the general
direction of the world in the long term.
Okay. All right. So now what I want to
talk about is China. What is China and
and what is China going to do? All
right. So again let's go back to our
theory of how the world works of how the
world is structured. You have the empire
and then from the empire you have the
game masters.
Okay the people in finance.
Then they create the global economy.
Then this creates the rule space
in actual order.
And then you have the
um education system,
media and culture
in order to indoctrinate people to
believe in the system that the system is
fair, right and natural. Okay. And then
you have parasitic organizations,
science, crime, intelligence
to control the system but also to draw
benefit to extract value from the
system. Now what we understand is that
the beauty of the system is that is
capable of extending itself and
replicating itself
in other societies. Okay. So the two
examples are
the GCC
and China.
Okay, this is really important for us to
appreciate. China is not a civilization.
China is not a nation state. China is a
construct of empire. Okay. China is what
the system has done is basically taken
all its elements and embedded itself
into
China to create
a vassal state.
Okay? Or you can also say a mirage.
And then you're like, okay, well, what
what does that mean? Well, just think of
the GCC where before the empire, the GCC
was just a desert and the empire, the
system takes the GCC and turns it into
this seemingly vibrant cosmopolitan
wealthy center. And then they bring in
the universities, right, like
Georgetown, NYU, they bring in um
culture, they bring in the media
ecosystem. So this system replicates
replicates itself into the GCC as well
as China. Now this is important because
the moment that this system is under
strain, okay, for example, Iran attacks
it, we see it's all just a mirage. This
system is not sustainable. It collapses
onto itself because it doesn't have a
civilization. It doesn't have an
existing soul. Okay? It's all just
appearance. And what I believe is that
China is in a very similar situation.
That's why China was allowed to join
WTO. That's why Chinese so many Chinese
students go overseas to become educated.
Okay. To create this mirage that China
is this modern flourished economy.
So um that this is China's relationship
to the world. So rather than believe
that China is competitor to the system,
we need to appreciate that China is
really an extension of the system. So if
this system comes under strain, China
itself comes under strain. That's why
China is so desperate, so anxious to see
peace in the Middle East again. Okay. So
there's there are rumors there's news
reporting that China has has ex exerted
pressure on Iran to negotiate a
ceasefire because if the global economy
collapses, China is in a lot of trouble.
All right. Okay.
[snorts]
Okay. So
um
what are long-term implications of the
Hollywood Pentagon complex?
Okay. And
um the answer is if you go back to the
system, okay, no one actually knows
what's going on, but they believe they
know what's going on and they believe
their individual parts of the story.
Okay? So if you're in culture, you think
you're the ones in control and you're
the one dictating policy. If you're in
the media, you think you're the ones in
control. If you're in education, you
think you're in control. Okay? So
everyone just basically lives in his own
bubble in in his own fantasy world
without being able to see the bigger
picture. And that's why we don't have
control and agency and free will over
how the system will turn out. Okay? And
we cannot because it's actually very
difficult for us to really appreciate
um how the system works. It's much
easier for us to believe in our
fantasies because it allows us to work
with our friends and our colleagues much
easier. Okay? It's much easier for
people to live in his own bubble and to
be delusional than it is for the person
to be objective. Okay?
So the Hollywood Pentagon complex, it is
not just unique to America. It is true
for everyone. How do emerging powers
like China um factor in the predict
shifts in global order? I already told
you that all these things that you
believe are alternatives including
digital currency, renewables, China.
They're all just projections, extensions
of the system. The system is under
strain, these are under strain as well.
Okay. What strategies can individuals
employ to navigate potential global
economic civil and resource scarcity?
Okay. So the problem is that individuals
by themselves cannot navigate change.
Individuals need to
enter into communities. Okay?
[snorts]
So if you really want to survive the
change, well first of all you need to
educate yourself as to what's going on.
And that's why I teach these classes to
give you the bigger picture as to how
the world works and where things are
going. But you also need to make need to
make a commitment to reach out to other
people, become their friends, be
generous and open with them, share with
them and build a community.
Okay. Also, one thing that I I would
recommend is maybe starting a family.
And the reason and you're like, okay,
wait a minute here. This is silly
because you have said for the longest
time, the world is collapsing. This is
the end of the world. Why would you have
children?
And the answer is because first of all
death doesn't matter. Destruction
doesn't really matter. What matters is
our ability in this world to live a
creative, purposeful, significant life.
Okay? That's why we're here. It's not
it's not to make a million dollars. It's
not to um eat a lot of food. It's to
have the best experience possible to
extend the imagination of the universe.
And what I found having children, I have
three kids, is that I live every day
with tremendous energy and purpose
because I'm here not to be become famous
or to make a lot of money. I'm here to
make sure that my kids have are happy
and healthy and that's why I get up in
the morning and work very hard. Okay? I
don't really care about the world. All I
care about is are my kids happy and
healthy. So children and family give you
a energy, a purpose, uh a meaning that
drives you to greater creative heights.
Okay. All right.
What are the primary drivers behind
specific geopolitical actions and how do
these motivates interact with a game
theory for? Okay. All right. So again,
this is a really important theory to
understand where the occultists are the
main drivers. Why? be the occultists
whether it be poets or prophets. They're
the ones who imagine the world we live
in. Okay? And we can and others can only
work within the boundaries of this
imagination.
So yes, the rich and the powerful, they
have all the money and all the wealth,
but they don't have an imagination.
So, and ultimately your actions have to
be driven by your thoughts. And it's
these a cultist, okay, who drive your
thoughts, who control your thoughts. So,
we just live in the world imagined by a
cultist. Who they are, what they want,
how they how they um work is something
that we'll discuss after the break.
Okay? After today, we're going to on a
oneweek break for the midterms and we'll
come back. We'll start more we'll talk
more about these people, the cultist.
Okay? They're very important people to
talk about. All right? So, let's move
on.
Okay, now I want I want to look at some
individual questions. All right, so this
is Joyce Lei from um Substack. She's a
founding member. So, thank you Joyce for
your generosity. Okay. Um she asked this
question.
You make three predictions about the
outcome of the US Iran war, but I don't
have any time frames. Yeah, I don't do
time frames because these things are
trends. Okay, they're general movements.
Okay, and she says, well, if all three
come true, then then we have to believe
that it may not be because of the war
itself. How do you differentiate between
causation and correlation? Okay, this is
a great question and this is something
that I think a lot about. So, I make
these predictions um in order to
validate my prediction model, but just
because these predictions turn out to be
correct does not validate my prediction
model 100%. Okay? And that's why it's
important to keep an open mind and to
continue to make predictions. Now, what
I will say is this. When I first started
making predictions two years ago, I was
just looking at patterns and then trying
to figure out what patterns were the
most salient or the most obvious. And
then I made those predictions and I was
fairly confident about these
predictions. Now that I'm famous, now
that people are demanding I make
predictions every day, it's hard for me
to make accurate predictions because I
don't have access to all the information
and it's hard for me to um think clearly
objectively because I know that whatever
I say is have an impact on global
events. Okay, so this is a major
constraint on my capacity to make
accurate predictions. I am no longer an
observer, I'm a player. Okay. And I also
get a lot of influence from other people
who want to control my predictions. I
understand that. So I try to keep away
from people as much as possible. But um
it's an impossible thing. So I so I
appreciate this question. Yes,
correlation and causation are two
different things altogether. Um it's
possible that we'll never really
understand causation. The other thing
that I I want to um emphasize is that I
I myself appreciate the limitations
to my own objectivity. Okay. Because of
my status today. Okay. So that's from
Joyce. Um isn't pump and every
politician just a puppet of the
societies? This is a great question.
It's something that that I addressed
earlier which is yes they are agents.
They can only be agents but at the same
time the agents have agency. The agents
have free will. So think of Napoleon and
Julius Caesar who and they were
obviously um supported by secret
societies but they reach a certain point
where they can betray the secret society
or vear off in a different direction.
And Hitler and Stalin are also different
examples. Okay. So every great person in
history, most of them are supported by
secret societies, but they also reach a
point where they feel they have a higher
calling and is God that they must be
loyal to. So they betray their um secret
society. And I think that something
something will happen with both Trump
and Vladimir Putin. Okay,
I have the third Rome. I have the
American technate and I have Pachida.
Wait a minute here. These are three
different empires. And the reality is
that this unipolar moment where America
controls everything, it is unique in
human history. It's not sustainable and
it will not last. So the idea of
competing empires, it's much more common
in human history. So yes, you'll have
the technate where America retreats into
greater North America. Russia exerts
control over uh its territory and Israel
tries to build a pax judica in the
Middle East and they will they will be
in competition against each other.
There'll be some areas in which they
cooperate. There are some areas in which
they compete and so we are moving
towards a multipolar world. Okay? And we
don't actually even know how long this
multipolar world will sustain itself.
probably not very long. Maybe 10 years,
maybe 20 years. Okay.
All right.
So, this question is um why would the
world be dependent on American
fertilizers, energy when the other parts
of the world have
um energy and fertilizers as well? And
the answer is trade access. Okay.
What America can do that other nations
cannot do is basically retreat into its
continental fortress
and control sea trade. Okay. So right
now the easiest way to trade is through
the sea. And unfortunately for the world
America controls the seas with its
navies. Okay. So what America can do is
basically allow its ships to go anywhere
in the world and block Chinese, Iranian,
Russian ships from accessing the rest of
the world. Now a counter to this is that
well you know you don't have to go by
sea. Um if you were to unite Europe,
Asia and Africa and the Middle East, you
can just use railways and that's what
China wants to do. The problem is Iran.
That's why America is so invested in
destroying Iran because Iran is really
the pivot of the world. If you can
destroy Iran, it'll be very hard for
China to access Belton Road um and hard
for Russia to trade with Africa. Okay.
All right. I would challenge Professor J
on his assessment of why Russia attacked
Ukraine. Um Russia was not prepared for
the long war and it adapted. Okay. Um
yeah. So the general theory, the general
explanation
is that NATO provoked Russia into an
attack. And that's true to a certain
extent, but we have to remember that if
you commit to a long war, if you commit
to any war, you need to have a long-term
strategy because you need so many
different organizations, institutions,
parties involved in a war. Okay? A war
means a fundamental restructuring of
society. And therefore you need a grand
strategy. You need a esquetology.
Okay? Because this is what allows for
political will.
And that's the issue that the Americans
are facing in Iran where they don't
really have um an esquetology or grand
strategy uh that's articulated. Okay.
There are people in America who do have
the grand strategy in esot esquetology
but it's not articulated to the American
people. Okay. And that's why America
doesn't really have the political will
to sustain this war in Iran. So again it
there's there's this misconception that
these [snorts] these people Putin Trump
they just work. They just have these
emotions like I want to go attack. So
they go attack. That's not how these
things work. Okay? You need a lot of
people [clears throat] to agree to
attack Ukraine, to attack to agree to
attack Iran before these things happen.
Okay? The the idea that one man can
control an entire country, it is just a
myth. It cannot happen that way. A
country is controlled by different
vested interests, different
institutions. These institutions have to
align together in order for something to
happen. Okay? Otherwise, they'll just
sit back and do nothing. And that's a
situation that um Iran faced in the
leadup to this war where everyone was
like, you know, the Americans, you know,
the Israelis are going to attack you, so
take the initiative. Why are you still
sitting around doing nothing? And the
answer is because there are different
factions, their different institutions
cannot align together on how to respond
to the Americans and Israel. So they
just sat back and wait to be attacked.
Okay. All right. [clears throat]
Um,
why don't Asian and Middle Eastern
nations unite to prevent American in
interference driven by its own interest?
Okay. Um, yeah.
[clears throat] Okay. Another
misconception is that the nation state
it is real. It is not real. It's just a
madeup concept. Okay. The idea of China,
the idea of America, the idea of Russia,
Iran, they're all madeup concept. They
don't exist. What these nation states
are are a collection of interests.
Collection of elite interests
and all this means is that [snorts]
the people don't matter. Okay, the
people are resource exploited by the
elite. What matters is the elite. So the
question then is where are the elite?
Where are their allegiances? Where are
their loyalties? The fact of the matter
is that in East Asia, in the Middle
East, mo much of the elite have their
family and have their wealth
all stored in the western world. So
they're not loyal to the people. They
are never loyal to the people. They're
loyal to themselves, to their families,
to the to their social network. And
because all of their wealth and family
is located overseas, they're loyal to
overseas. So these elite in Asia, in the
Middle East, they are basically carbon
baggers. Okay? And and and that's why we
have this um situation. And that's why
um as things progress, nations that have
very close relationships with the
Western world, for example, the GCC,
they are much likely to fall. They're
much likely to collapse because these
are these are very unstable countries.
Whereas um countries like Iran that have
been isolated, ostracized by the west
are much more cohesive. Okay. [snorts]
[clears throat]
All right.
Can the straight of moose be avoided by
laying gaps pipe through Oman? No. No.
That's not how these things work. Okay.
What Iran is doing is using circle moves
to blockade the global economy to disrup
the global economy. The circle moves is
the most convenient way of doing so. It
is the least controversial but if forced
to Iran can also destroy any energy
production in the GCC. It can destroy
the pipelines. If a drone can attack a
um city, it can attack a pipeline as
well. Okay, so these pipelines are
extremely vulnerable and and already
we're seeing reporting that just
yesterday the Iranians attacked a
pipeline in Saudi [clears throat]
Arabia. These pipelines are extremely
vulnerable. Just think about all this
gas and oil, right? It's all
combustible. So a drone can just blow it
up. It's not hard, right? So again,
understand the point is not the hummus.
The point is the vulnerability and the
fragility of the global economy that is
completely dependent on cheap access to
energy. That's where the problem lies.
All right. [clears throat]
All right.
Donald Trump, he's erratic. Do you
believe this behavior is calculated
strategy? Um or does it stem from lack
of understanding? Is he just stupid?
Do you think that people advising him
are also stupid or are they strategic?
What is he trying to achieve? Okay,
[clears throat] again um this go goes
back to our understanding of how the
world works. You have the esquetology,
then you have the secret societies, then
you have the agents. Okay, and Trump is
an agent. Now, what makes him a very
powerful agent is his unpredict
predictability.
Today he's like, I'm gonna nuke Iran.
Tomorrow he's like, let's have peace in
the world, guys. Okay, he's just
unpredictable. It's all a show. Okay.
And there are three reasons why
unpredictability is so powerful. The
first reason is that it's um paralyzing.
Paralyzing just means like you don't
know how to respond to him. Like what do
you do to how how do you fight a guy who
changes his his opinion every single
day? Okay, it paralyzes you into into uh
an action. Second is distracting
you. All your attention is focused on
his antics and you don't realize that
behind the scenes things are happening.
Okay, there are people who are
implementing certain things, but you
don't really notice the backstage
because you're just focused on Trump
being a clown on stage. Okay, and the
last advantage is flexibility,
which is say that he is not beholden to
any strategy
and he can change his strategy at any
time. Okay. So, yes, we think he's a
clown and he is a clown, but there's a
method to his madness. Okay. So, it
paralyzes enemies. It distracts his
enemies and he's able to maintain
maximum flexibility in his actions.
Okay. That's why he's so successful.
All right. Um the people around him just
do whatever he tells him to. People
around just tell him tells him exactly
what he wants to hear. Okay. It's it's
actually Donald Trump that's making all
the all the decisions and his ultimate
purpose is to get his third term.
All right? Because from his pers
perspective, if he actually wants to
implement his vision for America, he
needs the third term. Okay? And again,
his vision is a technate where America
becomes a fortress, abandons the world,
and just trades with the world. Okay? We
we discussed this previously. But for
him for him to achieve that, he needs
his third term. And so he needs to
figure out how to get his third term.
And this war in Iran is the best
strategy because if this war continues
and it goes badly for America, then uh
Trump can declare martial law and have a
lot of powers. Okay? And again, his en
his enemies are too distracted to
appreciate that this is strategic and
they're paralyzed into an action. the
Democratic party, which should be
opposing Trump and this war, are just
sitting back and doing nothing, hoping
that in the midterms, uh, Trump Trump's
party, the Republicans get wiped out and
they get they go into power and then the
world is perfect again. Okay. So, the
Democrats actually don't have a strategy
for this.
All right.
Um the GCC the petro dollar collapses
okay let's pretend the petro dollar
collapses
AI collapses treasury bond collapses
will the US not suffer an economic and
development catastrophe which is not
which is not part of the US plans yeah
this is a good question but you have to
understand again a nation state is a
collection of different interests and
these interests are competing against
each other okay so you have different
interest groups you have um AI you have
finance ants you have resources.
Okay.
And so what matters is the general
direction of the country. So if the
economy were to collapse, the main
losers would be finance and AI. Okay.
But then what America can do because
it's so wealthy and it's people are so
energetic is well let's just focus on
building resources. Okay. Oil, food, um
[snorts]
water, fertilizer. let's just make this
stuff and sell it to the world. Then the
economy um uh rebounds. Okay, so this is
actually a restructuring.
Okay, something we talked about before
where the purpose is not to destroy
America. The purpose is to move power
away from one elite to another elite.
Okay, this is basically a revolution in
America. AI can actually be saved. Okay,
uh with government bailout
and that's what I imagine will happen.
Okay, AI and finance the bubbles will
burst. Finance will be allowed to
collapse. AI will be bailed out because
Trump is very close with these AI
overlords like Peter Theo and Sen Alman.
And then resources will be resource
manufacturing, okay, will become the
dominant center of gravity in the
American economy. Okay, so that that's a
that's a plan. I'm not saying this will
happen exactly like this, but that's
what they have they they intend to
happen. All right.
Um, transial capital is a game master.
Um, transational capital will then take
its money elsewhere if the empire
collapses.
So, transial capital doesn't lose any
power
and they can just bet on different
horses. Japan, is Germany.
Um, okay. Yeah. So
in my analysis I use abstract terms
that are not accurate but some but are
useful for simplicity and clarity. Okay.
So you're writing that transnational
capital also have competing interests
and just because the empire empire
collapses doesn't mean that all the
money goes to Israel. This money will
spread out and that's true. Okay. But
the point the point I'm trying to make
is that first of all, most of the money
will go to Israel. Why? Because Israel
provides the best short-term investment
opportunities if you're a trillionaire.
Okay? But you're right in that other
money will go to other places as well.
But again, the best opportunity is
Israel. So you will see the most growth
in Israel. And that's why over time more
capital will shift towards Israel.
That's how capital works. Okay. [snorts]
Yes, capital will um allocate its
resources. Capital will uh put its um
eggs in different baskets, but
ultimately you have to ask yourself
where is the best investment opportunity
and in the short term, not in the long
term, but in the short term, it's going
to be the Middle East. Okay. All right.
How do we combat the war against truth?
How do we engage in discussion that
transitional biases? Okay. Um, we all we
all live in fantasies. How do we
overcome this? What techniques do you
employ in your research? All right.
Okay. So, um, things I do that I think
are very important is first of all,
doubt.
You always want to question yourself.
You always want to ask yourself, am I
correct? That's why making predictions
is important because making predictions
it's actually about creating doubt in
yourself because if the predictions are
wrong it's a mechanism for you to
self-reflect and appreciate the
limitations of your model. Okay, so
that's one strategy. Another strategy is
debate.
Okay, where you engage in people who
think differently than you do. And I do
that by watching a lot of YouTube
videos. And I try to try to watch people
of different political leanings, who
have different viewpoints than I,
because I'm interested in hearing their
perspective. Okay? So, keep an open
mind. Engage in people who disagree with
you and have an honest debate with them
as well as yourself. Now, the last
piece, and this is actually something
that I do, but most people don't do, is
I use my imagination.
And all this means is I will go places.
I will make certain assumptions that
other people don't do. Okay, that that's
why I think people find me so
interesting because I will say things
that are imaginative that are
speculative but which is not backed up
by any evidence. Don't be afraid to do
that. Okay. If you want to seek the
truth, you have to make some imaginative
leaps. into leaps into the unknown in
order to um find the truth. Okay, the
truth is not in front of you. The truth
is often behind you or far away from
you. Okay, so you need to be you don't
be afraid to just leap far, okay, into
the unknown. All right. [clears throat]
All right, let's continue.
Okay,
so Asia and Australia are suffering the
most from this global conflict. Why are
these nations passive?
Um
won't these nations intervene?
Okay, again
um a lot of this is misconception in
that everyone thinks that the nation
states are the constituent uh players in
this game and the nation states are all
equal. They're not equal. They're not
nation states. There only certain nation
states that have the capacity to project
force overseas. Russia, America, maybe
some European countries. Australia,
uh, Asia and most European countries are
just vassal states. They they are not
capable of playing this game. They're
only capable of obeying. Okay? Maybe
over time they will change attitude and
develop the capacity to play this game.
But you have to remember that like the
GCC, a lot of these European countries,
Japan, South Korea, Malaysia, Indonesia,
Philippines, they're all co-opted by the
CIA. Okay? These are all American
national vassel states. And so they're
not capable of acting independently of
American policy. There's the illusion
that they are independent, but they're
not. Okay? And you can tell because of
their actions in that you're absolutely
right in that. Okay, if you're Australia
and you don't have any more jet fuel,
well then you should send your army or
negotiate with Americans or negotiate
with Iranians. But they're not doing
that. Okay. Japan is in fact negotiating
with Iran,
but Japan is still vassal state of
America. Pakistan
is the mediator for
uh this
ceasefire talk between America and Iran.
But guess what? Pakistan is also just
another vassal state. Okay, they pretend
pretend not to be but just be but by
their actions you know that they are in
fact vassal states. All right. Okay.
Um civil war breaks out. Who's going to
win? Uh Christian nationalist Silicon
Valley versus the Oman Wall Street. a
city versus country like conflict do you
believe it will result in separation of
union into multiple factions okay so if
you look at the history of the Roman
republic once a civil war starts it
almost never ends okay that's just the
nature of American society where America
is so vast and people are so energetic
and ambitious that once the civil war
starts [music] it's very unlikely that
it will ever stop. Okay, maybe maybe the
intensity will shift over time but uh
you will have civil war for the next few
hundred years. Okay, and the question
then is who triumphs? Okay. So, if you
just use our game theory formula, okay,
of cohesion,
[snorts] energy,
and openness, and you ask yourself,
okay, let's just look at American
society and ask yourself, which state
has all three? The answer is Texas.
Okay?
And this is pretty clear. If you just
look at the 50 states and which state is
the most dynamic, which is the most um
energetic, the most open-minded, it's
going to be Texas. California, New York
are going to suffer in the civil war.
The economies will suffer a great deal.
The sides will suffer a great deal.
Texas will emerge as a clear winner in
any conflict. Okay? And with um uh
Texas, you also have Christian
nationalists
and AI. Okay. Why Christian nationalist?
Because Christian nationalist is
actually a coherent philosophy.
It's coherent. It it has a direction. It
has a strategy. It has a purpose. Okay.
Okay. So I think Christian nationalists
will also win out and then AI will win
out because um AI can provide the
technological support to Christian
nationalists. Okay. So if you are
working in Texas, if you live in Texas
and if you work in AI and you're a
Christian nationalist, well, you're
going to be a big winner of this civil
war. Okay? I mean, if you if you if
you're the opposite, okay? If you are
maybe living in New York or California
and you work and you are maybe an
atheist and you I don't know work in
arts, I don't know. Well, you're going
to be a clear loser in this
[clears throat] war. Okay. Often these
uh what's called professional
managerial elite
professional man managerial elite living
the coast. These guys are done. Okay.
completely useless, cost too much money,
contributes nothing to society. These
guys are just done. All right.
All right.
How does an individual survive for
what's coming? Family and community,
guys. Okay. Forget the fact that you are
an individual. Leave that behind. You
will not survive as an individual. I
don't care how much money you have. I
don't care
um how prepared you are. You might have
a B bunker. I don't know. I don't care.
Okay. But you have to focus on family
community if you are to survive the new
world. All right.
All right. Do you think Iran should have
nuclear weapons?
No.
The worst thing Iran can do at this
point is develop a nuclear weapon. Iran
can at most have 10 nuclear weapons.
America has a thousand. There's one way
for Iran to lose this war really quickly
and it's to threaten America with a
nuclear weapon because that gives
America justification to um use it
nuclear arsenal. Okay. But the other
problem and this is actually more more
important problem is the idea of
complacency
where if you think you have nuclear
weapons or sorry if you have nuclear
weapons you think you're I'm safe. I
don't have to worry about anything.
No, no, no.
It's much better to be creative and
resilient and open-minded. Okay? So if
you don't have nuclear weapons, you're
always under threat, right? that forces
forces your people in your society to
constantly think about how to be
strategic.
All right. So nuclear weapons is a bad
thing. It's not a good thing.
All right. Paka
doesn't Saudi Arabia see that coming?
Why would they allow that to happen?
Well, because
um for Saudi Arabia, what matters is
first defeating Iran. Because the the
strategy is I defeat Iran, then I'm I'm
master of the of the Muslim world. So I
can unite the all the two billion
Muslims in the world behind me to defeat
Israel. Okay. So from a perspective of
the GC and Saudi Arabia, uh Iran is a
much bigger threat than Israel. Um why
have hasn't the GC anything about what
has happened in uh Palestine and
Lebanon? The GCC are quote vassel states
of America. All right. just it's not
it's not hard. These are all run by the
CIA.
Um if Trump is a genius, why do you
authorize the insane and stupid film
mission to steal uranium
uranium? Iranian uranium. Okay. All
right. This is a really good question
and the answer is this. Trump is a
genius at politics. He's a genius at
screwing over his enemies and
accumulating power for himself. He is
not a military genius. Okay?
He's a Trump is a genius at um
controlling his base. [cough]
Trump is a genius at being a TV star.
He's not a genius at geopolitics.
Okay? These things the these things
don't have to be the same. All right?
How can Israel sustain a global empire
um when their religious leaders view the
physical destruction of their own cities
as a spiritual victory?
Um okay,
it's not that hard to rebuild an economy
and a city. It's not okay. What is hard
though is to develop the spiritual
cohesion of a people to make them
believe in something so that they're
willing to die for it. Okay, that's what
matters. All right, destroying a city
you can rebuild in 5 years time. It's
not that hard. Just hire the Chinese to
do it. Okay, a nuclear taboos. Um
why would they respect a rational
escalation ladder to avoid using nudes?
Okay, that's a really good question. If
these people are religious and they're
fanatical and they're crazy, why do they
care about nukes? And the answer is they
don't care about nukes. They they think
this world is fake. Okay, but the
problem is that nuclear weapons, there
are institutional constraints and
restraints on the use of nuclear
weapons. Okay, so there's this myth that
Donald Trump can just press one bit
button and all the nukes will go flying.
That's not how it works. Okay, there are
lots of subtle constraints on the
president. Okay, he has to go get the
nuclear football. Then someone has to
open for him and then he can press a
button.
But if people think Donald Trump is
crazy, I guarantee you that nuclear
football guy is going to run away. Okay,
there's so many taboos against the use
of nuclear weapons. Again I keep on
saying this but if nuclear weapons are
used in this war we are completely
screwed. Okay I don't think nuclear
weapons will be used in this war. All
[snorts] right if mass organization are
the primary cause of imperial decay
where unlimited population unlimited
land so reasons the US techn will
succeed.
Um okay all right look um I I said the
US technate is a plan. I didn't say it
would it would succeed. Yes, I
understand America can take over all of
North America. It can occupy Canada. It
can occupy Mexico, Cuba. But when it
does that, it's going to create a lot of
insurgencies. It's going to create a lot
of conflict. So, um it it will be a
dumpster fire. Okay? Just because you
are able to accomplish it doesn't mean
you should accomplish it. Doesn't mean
it doesn't mean it'll be successful. Uh
immigration trap. Why is conforming the
rules and working hard consider playing
the game wrong? If high confidence
require resilience in the coming era of
resource scarcity. Um
um look if the game is fair you want to
conform to rules and you want to work
hard but if there's an elite that is
parasitic that is rent seeeking then by
working hard you're just transferring
your energy to the elite. Okay. So
before maybe 20 20 years ago, America
was a place that was very fair and so if
you just worked hard
uh and played by rules, you would
succeed. This is no longer true where
it's basically an oligarchy and where a
few people control all the u power.
Okay.
All right.
Iranians are growing less religious.
Um and so as this war becomes as this
war continues the framework of Shia
modern will energize Iranians become
more cohesive and the answer is yes. One
outcome this war uh that we should
expect is that Iranian society becomes
much more religious much more fanatical.
All right and one reason is that the
Americans are intent on destroying
Iranian urban centers like Tran. Okay.
So the Americans and the Israelis are
bombing railway networks that connect
Iran uh Tran to the countryside and so
Tran might not have access to food which
case um Tran might disappear as a city.
In that case when people are in
desperate need they turn to religion as
to for comfort. Okay. And then they have
this escological drive. So yes we can
expect uh Iran to become much more
esqueological as this war continues.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, the US implements a draft.
Generation Z refuses.
Um, you have a civil war. Then where's
the US military going to get its
soldiers?
Okay, that's a good question. And the
answer is illegal immigrants. Okay,
there about 28 million illegal
immigrants in America.
um they can be arrested and they can be
conscripted. Okay, so that's a solution
to this problem because as he points
out, young people are not going to fight
in this war because it's suicidal. All
right,
what if you can make cheap drones? Okay.
So, so I say, you know, the way to
counter cheap drones is with a ground
invasion. But America, America can make
even cheaper drones than um wouldn't
that solve the problem?
And
yeah, so the answer is this.
We become too
obsessed with technology. We think that
technology can solve all the problems.
And what you don't understand, what
people don't appreciate is that
technology is built on people. Okay?
[snorts]
Technology is meant to compleimement
people, to enhance the skills of people.
Technology is not designed to replace
people. That's the issue that America is
facing this war where America thinks
that by using sophisticated air defense,
by using uh super carriers, by using
fighter jets that are stealth, we can
reduce civilian casualties and win the
war. And it's turning out not to be the
case. Why? Because people are much more
creative, much more resilient, and much
more determined than technology. Okay?
So if you have a group of people
together, they're going to figure
they're always going to figure out a way
to defeat your technology.
Uh so imagine this, okay? You build a
robot and this robot is invincible.
Lots of machine guns,
uh nighttime vision, 360 vision. Okay,
if I fight this robot one to one, I'm
dead, right? But I'm I'm a human being.
I'm not stupid. So, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to lure this robot into a
dark forest or a cave where the robot's
going to stumble and where I can maybe
throw a rock or pour water on it. Okay?
But, but because
um technology it's static,
people are dynamic and creative, okay,
and spontaneous.
So that's what makes people people so
wonderful because we humans we're
dynamic. We're creative. We're
spontaneous. We're not afraid to die for
what for what we believe in. A robot is
just going to do what a robot's going to
do. So it's completely predictable. We
are not predictable. Okay? That's why if
you insist on using technology and
drones as your main military strategy,
you will lose this war. You have to
commit your people to total war. You
have to find people who are willing to
die for what they believe in and then
you'll win this war. And that's why I
believe that ultimately America will
will lose this war in Iran because the
American people don't have the global
will to fight this war. I don't care how
much money you put in this war. You're
going to spend hundred trillion dollars.
I don't care. I don't care how much
technology you have. You're still going
to lose this war unless you're able to
galvanize the patriotism and political
will of your people. Okay.
All right.
Israel be humbled.
Doesn't that not change Pax Judeica?
Okay. All right. Okay. So, Pax Judeica
and Israel are not the same thing.
Pax Judea is a project of transnational
capital. So, think of Israel as the
host, Pax Judeica as the parasite. Okay?
And the same thing happened in America
where at the end of the 19th century you
have all this transational capital
coming into America through Wall Street
and through um uh manufacturing the
economy. They were able to control
America for the Federal Reserve. Okay.
So transnational capital is the
parasite. America is the host. So in
this situation, Israel is the host and
Patria will be the parasite or
transnational capital. Okay. So it
doesn't matter what happens to Israel.
They can bomb Israel to smiththerines.
Doesn't matter. Who cares? Because
transational capital can come into the
region, hire Chinese, Filipinos, Indians
to rebuild Israel. Okay.
Um, is the war going to transfer the
transfer accept transfer wealth from the
old to the young in the US or worsen it?
Okay. Yeah, this is an excellent
question. This is a a really a key
question if you really understand
geopolitics. The answer is as this war
continues, as chaos um continues
throughout the world, more money will be
transferred to the old
than to the young. Okay? So all this
inequalities, this generational
inequality that we're seeing in America
will worsen. And the reason why is that
in a time of chaos, in a time of
conflict, okay, capital
um always triumphs. Okay. And the reason
why is that capital is able to foresee
risk
to um uh distribute risk properly and
take advantage of risk. Okay. If I have
trillion dollars, it's almost impossible
for me to lose my money and I can make
more money. Okay? So imagine a situation
where, okay, I have $2. I'll invest a
billion in America, a billion in Iran, a
billion in Israel. I can't possibly lose
this war. Okay? But you have like a
$1,000, I guarantee you, you're going to
lose all your money. And the reality
right now is that the old um not all the
old, but a minority of the old, the
oligarchy have all the capital, and
young have nothing. Okay? So it's the
young who will give up all their money
to the old and the young who will be
asked to die in the Middle East so that
the old can maintain their power. Okay.
And that's a historical pattern.
Um
[clears throat]
AI okay civil war AI Republicans finance
Democrats.
Um,
okay.
Absolutely correct in that these
categories are not that simple.
It's a very fluid situation where AI is
going to bet on both Democrats and
Republicans. Finance is going to bet
both on um Republicans and Democrats.
But for the sake of my analysis, I
create these categories so that I can
project into the future. I can
extrapolate into the future. But you're
absolutely right in that these
categories are problematic. Okay.
[snorts]
All right.
America's plan is to weaken the global
economy by letting the war drag on. Um,
if the US wants if Iran wants the US to
leave the why how can Israel still
achieve its plan?
Um, okay. First question. Is America
trying to slowly weaken the global
economy by letting the war drag on? Uh,
and the answer is it's not intentional,
but it's a consequence. Meaning, America
can suffer the consequence of the
collapse of the global economy because
America is self-sufficient and can it
can always retreat back into its
fortress. It's the global economy that
will that will suffer. So it will seem
in hindsight that America had this
planet all along when in reality it's
just because no matter what America
does, it always wins. Okay, that's a
benefit of being America. No matter what
you what happens, you always win. All
right. Um Iran wants us to leave. But
then how can Israel achieve the greater
Israel project? And the answer is Israel
will not let the US leave. Okay.
[clears throat]
Um I I mean Israel right now is a
parasite. US is is a host. Once US
leaves, Israel becomes a host. Pax da
transational capital becomes a parasite.
Okay. So there's no way the US is going
to leave the GCC region. [snorts] Um
will the two weeks CR hold? Um
no. Okay. No. Forget the ceasefire. It's
all theater. it and like think about who
who is negotiating a ceasefire. You have
J Kushner and you have CIO. The same two
guys that screw up the negotiations
which led to this war in Oman. Okay. And
then where where is this taking place?
It's taking place in Pakistan which is a
vassal state of the United States. So
these negotiations will go nowhere. All
right.
How do you fit variables and general
human unpredictability in your game
theory model? Um, yeah, that's a really
good question. Okay, the answer is I
don't use math.
It's impossible to mo to model random
human behavior. It's just impossible.
Maybe maybe if if I had like a million
years of data, I could do that. But I
can't do that. I have like a few hundred
years of data. So, I don't even use
math. I know it's game theory. I know
you and I and I know supposed to use
math but but I'll be constrained by
math. Okay. So I I use a lot of
intuition. I use a lot of doubt. I use a
lot of debate. Okay. So doubt, debate,
imagination. Um how would
Okay. So Israel is a prize state. How
can they achieve peska? Okay. Okay. So
this is confusing for people but like
public opinion does not matter in
geopolitics.
Rome was this genocidal state. No one
cared. It didn't care. It still became
the empire lasted for a thousand years.
Okay? Even today, we still worship Rome.
The Aztecs were known for human
sacrifice. Didn't matter. They still
became the empire of Mexico. Uh the
British, the British h they created all
these wars in Europe. They enslaved the
Indian population and destroyed their
economy and stole tranz from them. They
addicted Chinese to opium. Do we ever
talk about this? I mean like if we had
opinion poll back in the 1850s, I think
most of the world would be like the
British Empire is evil.
They're genocidal.
We still worship the British Empire
today. Okay. So public opinion does not
matter. We've come to this delusion that
our opinions matter in geopolitics. It
doesn't matter in geopolitics. What
matters is power. Okay.
[clears throat]
Oh, that's it, guys. Wow. Oh, well.
Okay. All right. We did it, guys. We we
we did the midterm. Okay. So, hopefully
I did well on this midterm. We're also
have a final examination. Um, so I look
forward to that. But thank you for the
questions and uh we will take a oneweek
break next week and then we'll come back
and continue um game theory and our
analysis of the US Iran war. So um any
questions?
>> Yeah. So
>> okay.
So uh I have like two main questions and
Vincent also sent me some of his
questions like uh so uh my first
question is about the global economy
like in your previous discussion you
argue that the US centric global economy
system would collapse after the Iraq war
leading to the remilitarization of
various nations and severely disrupt
disrupting the global trade. However,
why a new like global economic system
created uh on one or few countries will
not be well would not like uh emerge
because even though this system should
uh would inevitably create significant
inequality among the countries, it would
still bring substantial wealth and
econom economic benefits to
participating nations. Why create uh
which I think will create motivation for
these country building.
>> Okay.
>> Uh yeah. And uh historically after the
age of explorations, I think the
collapse of each imperial systems lead
to the rise of the new uh empires. For
example, the Spanish maritimes collapse
and the British empire gradually
replaced and after the world war and two
the American became the empire and that
replaced the British like so why won't
this happen again?
>> Okay. Okay. So the basis of the of the
global economy is the US dollar. Okay.
So what is the US dollar? The US dollar
is basically a contract system.
[clears throat]
Okay. So when I use US dollar basically
it's a contract that our trade will be
honored. Okay. Right. But with contract
system you also need need an enforcement
mechanism.
[clears throat]
Okay? Meaning, look,
if you don't if you don't honor the
contract, then someone has to come beat
you up, right? Otherwise, you'll just
ignore the contract. So, that's what the
US military is for.
All right. [clears throat]
Now, there are certain problems with
this system. The first problem is that
it's actually very costly
to create a contract system. Okay? Why?
Because you are absorbing all the risk.
Okay? So you're the US economy. You
print US dollars to enable the world to
trade with each other. Okay? But when
you do that, you are collecting a tax.
But at the same time, it's putting
tremendous strain on your economy.
Okay, because
this leads to finan financialization
which is just risk and speculation.
[clears throat]
Okay. So all this excess money is being
created around the world and you have to
absorb it into your economy which causes
inflation which causes things to be
unaffordable to your people. All right,
so that's the first problem. Okay, it's
really expensive on the population. The
population in America must absorb the
cost of access liquidity in the world.
Okay, does that make sense? Okay, the
second problem is the military.
The military must be willing to fight
any wars
around the world at any time.
Okay. So the question then is are there
is there any nation in the world besides
America that's one willing to absorb the
cost of creating a contract system being
the global reserve currency and number
two that's willing to fight a war to
enforce this mechanism anytime anywhere
in the world and the answer is no hell
no okay this system is
it is unbelievable that America agreed
to the system in the first place and and
most Americans would say, well, we just
got stuck with this system and certain
people benefited from the system, but
most people don't actually benefit from
the system. So, the idea that anyone is
going to come and said, oh, you know,
we'll just take over the system, whether
it be Russia or China, that's just
okay? No one's going to no
one's going to replace America. So, the
global economy is is just going to
fracture because again, no one's willing
to to accept the cost to be the global
reserve currency. It's just too
expensive.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. But so uh uh why why cannot like
some regional powerful country like
Japan and German as you mentioned before
or American like they form into a group
that well together build a global
economic systems
because ultimately you have to resolve
the issue of um uh benefit. Okay.
Okay. Like we have to negotiate who
benefits.
Okay. Doesn't make sense.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's hard for nation states to
figure that out. It's much easier to
have an empire. It's much easier for me
to impose my power on to you. But for us
to like work together peacefully, maybe
for a couple years, okay? But it's very
unsustainable.
All right? Because why? Because of
domestic concerns. which your population
will want to maximize the benefit from
this relationship.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh so uh my second question is about
the uh the the the value of the the the
culture of the world. Uh as we discussed
before this world today is highly
materialistics with money and the
pursuit of material possessions becoming
the main driving forces in society. and
uh in your vision of the in the future
believe that people will place greater
emphasize on religion and spiritual
life. But how exactly will this
transformation occur? Because um if this
will occur through like war or suffering
then [clears throat] uh as in history we
go through like war one and war many
people die and many tragedy happen. But
it seems that this value this
materialistic value doesn't change
because that's what what we have today.
>> Okay. So I didn't say everyone will
experience this transformation. What I'm
saying is that those who undergo the
transformation will most likely survive
the coming world collapse. Okay? So you
can choose like I I want to be
materialistic. You can do that and most
people will choose to continue to want
to be materialistic but they won't
survive. Okay? And those who do undergo
the transformation will survive. And why
do they undergo the transformation?
Because they see the world collapsing
around them and they and they are
looking for comfort. They're looking for
a story. They're looking for an
explanation. And so they turn to
religion. Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay. And the reality is that look in
the coming 50 years of all this chaos
and war I would say 90% of humanity will
be wiped out and a lot of these people
will be because they refuse to adapt to
the new world. They refuse to believe
that a new world is coming and they
should prepare for it. Okay. They refuse
to change their minds. Okay. Any more
questions?
>> Uh yeah. Uh I have some question of like
you want me to ask?
>> Uh maybe two. Okay.
>> Okay. Yeah. Uh the first is like he he
he had some question about our
uh ours as an individuals in this world.
He said that if our efforts are defined
based on the consequ consequentialism of
secret society and other definitions,
what is the significance of our efforts?
Is isn't it still exacerbating the
secret society? Do we have a way to
define our own value? Can or can we only
live in the eye of others? Yeah, it's
absolutely pointless to worry about
societies. It's absolutely pointless to
worry about others. What you can do is
live your life to the best of your
ability. Okay? You can be uh focused on
learning, on developing yourself
spiritually and intellectually and
emotionally. You can be focused on
reading books, on asking questions.
Okay? And if you do that, you'll be
fine. So stop worrying about secret
societies, stop worrying about the end
of the world and just focus on your own
personal transformation. Okay.
>> All right. One more question is uh
related to the uh Chinese student uh he
me he said that how do you think Chinese
students who are currently studying in
the United States will be perceived in
the future while Chinese people
discriminate against us uh US American
students in the future.
Look, the reality is that the age of
globalization is over. The idea that
Chinese students learn English, hop on a
plane, go to America, study for four
years, and come back and get a good job,
that era is over. And quite honestly,
I'll be honest with you, I don't even
know why Chinese students do this in the
first place. Okay. Um, again, I think a
lot of it has to do do with the fact
that China is not a real nation state.
It's just a projection.
mirage created by the global economy.
Um, but I mean
I mean Chinese students now are focused
on getting the degree in America. It's
just a piece of paper. Chinese students
don't care enough about an education
about learning. Okay, that's that's a
great myth about Chinese students in
this world where Chinese students are
the best in the world because Chinese
students love learning and are
disciplined. That's not true. Chinese
students are extremely
um extrinsically motivated. They care
about the grades. They care about the
degree. Once you take that away from
Chinese students, Chinese students don't
even know what to do. They play video
games every day. They just sit around
and do nothing. Okay? So, if Chinese
students are to thrive in the future,
they need to learn passion. They need to
learn interesting motivation. They need
to love learning for itself.
All right. Okay. All right. So, that is
it. Thank you for the midterm. Um, and I
will see everyone the week after. Okay,
so we're taking a break next week.